Life is a manifestation of where you
direct your energy.
It truly is,
and what we should really start with is
to actually look at energy the same way
we look at water.
If I took water,
if I took a watering can and water the
garden bed with the weeds,
grow,
the flowers grow both right?
What?
It has no ability to discriminate
between the weeds and the flowers.
Whatever water starts growing and it is
the same way as well.
If I took energy and I invested it into
something negative,
it will grow and become more negative.
If I took energy,
invested it into something positive,
it will grow and become more positive.
Energy has no ability to discriminate
between what's positive and what's
negative.
Whatever you invest energy into starts
to grow and manifest in your life right
now.
You are the sum total of where you've
been investing your energy throughout
your entire life.
So the goal really in life is to figure
out what it is you want,
right?
What's your purpose in life?
Who and what's important in your life,
and be able to direct energy too.
It's that so that you can manifest that
in your life.
So where do we begin with this?
We begin by understanding how the mind
works.
I'll have to say with you,
after living 10 years as a celibate monk
in a cloistered monastery in Hawaii,
this would probably be the most
important thing I could ever share with
you.
Understanding how the mind works from
amongst perspective of understanding a
monk and experience of a month's
attractive.
I've understanding the mind and
experience at the mine in my
perspective,
in my experience of the mind,
the two things we need to understand
awareness and the mine,
let's define what they are.
Let's define awareness as a glowing ball
of light.
So imagine an ob,
a glowing ball of light that can float
around.
Let's call it awareness and put that
aside.
Now let's define the mind.
Let's define the minus a vast space with
many different areas.
Within one area of the mind is angry,
hatred,
jealousy,
jai happiness,
sex,
food,
art,
science,
technology,
whole bunch of different things,
right?
Yo awareness that ball of light can
actually move to any area of the mind
you want it to go to.
So if your awareness,
this glowing ball of light goes to,
they're happier of the mind,
it lights up that particular area of the
mind.
You become,
you become conscious of being happy.
Are you happy?
No.
You're in an area of the mind call
happiness.
If this ball of light goes to the
angrier of the mind,
it lights up that particular area of the
mind.
Are you angry?
No.
You in an area of the mind called
hangar.
And by using your willpower and your
powers of concentration,
you can actually take your awareness as
well of late to any area of the mind
that you want to go to.
And here's the most important part where
your awareness goes.
That's where your energy is flowing.
So if your awareness goes to the angrier
of the mind,
your energy is flowing that it's
actually strengthening that particular
area of the mind.
So this is the theory of it.
So let's do a little practical exercise
to see if this actually works of some
mung talk.
Okay.
So for that they need some audience
participation.
They need all of you to sit up straight
in your chair.
Okay?
And put your feet down on the ground.
And if you're leaning in your chair,
sit forward a little bit.
Keep your spine straight,
roll your shoulders back and keep your
head nicely balanced on top of your
spine.
Your eyes are closed.
Don't worry,
we're not going to chat.
Oh,
hold hands until later.
Just kidding.
Uh,
so take a slow deep breath in with your
eyes closed.
Take a slow deep breath in.
Slowly exhale.
Then take another slow deep breath in
again.
And then slowly exhale.
I want you to become aware of the
chatter that you're sitting on.
Is it comfortable?
Is it not comfortable?
The temperature of the room?
Is it cold?
Warm?
What about your body posture?
Is your spine straight?
Your shoulders roll back,
your sitting a little bit forward,
your head nicely balanced on top of your
spine.
Now I want you to become aware of the
most recent wedding that you attended.
Do you remember whose wedding it is?
Where are you happy for the couple
getting married?
Trying to think as much detail as you
can about the wedding.
Do you remember what you wore to the
wedding?
Do you remember what the bride wore?
Did she make a good choice with a dress?
How was the food at the wedding?
Alcohol.
Did you drink a lot?
Was that good music?
Did you dance?
Did you do some crazy wedding dance?
Now I want you to become aware of the
most recent vacation that you went on.
What kind of vacation was it?
Was it a surfing trip?
Yoga retreat.
Holiday shopping.
Camping.
Backpacking?
Yeah.
Try and think as much detail as you can
about the vacation.
What was the weather like where you
went?
Was it cold,
rainy,
hot,
humid,
dry,
snowing?
Do you remember the favorite hotel you
stayed in?
How was the food land?
Spicy.
Did you get sick eating the food?
Did you shop a lot?
What was one thing you bought on the
trip that you really liked?
Your eyes are still closed.
I want you to become aware of the room
again.
Try and feel the temperature of the
room.
Is it warm?
Is it cold?
The chair you're sitting on.
Is it comfortable?
Is it not?
It's your spine still straight or you're
hunching your shoulders roll back.
Okay.
Slowly open your eyes and you can lean
back in your chat.
Well,
thank you very much for doing that
exercise with me that the exercise is
really to prove two things to you.
One is this a clear separation between
awareness and the mind.
Two completely different things.
Second is you can actually take your
awareness and move it to any area of the
mind you want it to go to.
Well,
you gave me permission,
do it.
So I took your awareness from the room.
I took it to an area of the subconscious
mind where the memory of the wedding
recited and then I took you to the
vacation area of the mine and then back
to the room again.
How do I know you were thinking about
the wedding?
Well,
I had my eyes open and your eyes were
closed and when to ask questions.
I could see the reactions in your face
to the bride.
Make a good choice with her dress.
A couple of UN.
Okay.
Did you drink too much?
A few heads went down,
so I knew you were thinking about the
wedding,
right?
So I took your awareness,
different areas in the mind.
This happens to all day,
all day.
We allow people and things around us to
dictate where awareness goes in their
mind.
Let's do one little exercise again,
just to emphasize this point because to
me this is really,
really important and it's the crack of
crux of really managing energy in your
life.
Can you remember your first kiss?
Do you remember who it was?
Do you remember his or her name?
Do you remember where it took place?
Back at dad's car.
Behind the garage.
What was the experience?
So what was the emotion that was
associated with the experience
from a real,
think about it wasn't that long ago.
Come on,
we embarrassed,
we nervous.
Do you remember?
Do you remember the person's name?
Okay.
Some people are laughing,
blushing.
Do you remember the first time someone
you loved,
someone really close to you,
passed away?
Do you remember that?
Do you remember getting a phone call
being told that this person that you
love has just died?
How did you feel?
What was the emotions associated with
that experience?
Did you have the blessing of being able
to see the body before they was cremated
or buried?
Do you remember standing next to the
body wondering how it felt knowing that
you'll never see this person again?
How did it feel for you?
Do you remember the emotions?
Isn't it interesting?
In the space is 60 to 90 seconds.
I take your awareness from an area of
the mind where all of you are smiling or
giggling or slightly embarrassed to an
area of the mine where all of you are
completely sad and that Saturday just
feeling the vibration of the rooms has
completely changed,
right?
And I could take your awareness now to
an angry area of the mind where you all
get anger,
you get up and you leave and Sarah and
her team would be really upset with me
and this happens all day,
right?
All Day.
We allow people and things to dictate
where awareness goes and because they
dictate where awareness goes.
That's where our energy flows as well
and where our energy flows is what
manifest in our life.
So really the goal in is not really to
control your mind,
but rather to control where your
awareness is going it within your mind.
So don't control your mind.
Control where your awareness goes within
your mind.
How do we do that?
We do that by learning how so your
spiritual practice or your homework for
taking away is to control where your
awareness goes in your mind throughout
the day.
And that's really it.
How do we do this?
We learn the fine art of concentration.
First,
let's define what concentration is.
I define concentration as the ability to
keep your awareness on one thing for an
extended period of time.
So if I can keep my awareness on this
lady and hold it on her,
I'm concentrating.
If I around with my awareness,
my ball of light to move away,
I'm getting distracted,
I use my willpower and I bring my
awareness back and I hold it on her.
Being able to do that allows me to
concentrate.
Most people can't concentrate for two
reasons,
right?
One is they've never been taught how to
concentrate.
Second is they never practice
concentration.
How many of you growing up here in
school have classes on concentration
every single day?
The same way you had classes on
geography,
on math and science?
Anybody?
I travel all around the world and I
asked this question and nobody puts
their hand up.
How many of you,
when you were growing up in school,
we're told to concentrate?
Isn't that amazing?
You get tall to concentrate,
but you never get taught how to do it.
Right?
When I was growing up,
I got told to concentrate all the time.
Dandapani concentrate on doing your
homework.
Dandapani concentrate on eating your
food.
Anybody want to show me how to do it?
No.
How many of you have kids?
How many of you telling your kids to
concentrate?
Have you ever showed them how to know?
Right?
And then if you don't show them how to
concentrate,
how would they know how to do it?
And then if you want to be good at
something,
you have to practice it.
If you want to be really good at
concentration,
you need to practice it all day.
People are good at distraction because
that's what they practice all day long.
It's not that they don't have the
ability to concentrate,
they've just practice distraction and
then become really,
really good at it.
So how do we concentrate?
We concentrate by practicing doing one
thing at a time and integrating this
practice into our everyday life.
So for me,
I look at my average day and I asked
myself,
what's a reoccurring event in my life?
Everyday I speak with my spouse.
Every time I speak with my spouse,
I give her my undivided attention.
I keep my awareness on her.
It drifts away.
I bring it back,
it drifts away.
I bring it back.
I keep my awareness on her.
I give her my undivided attention.
Now every day I also speak to my
clients.
So I speak with my clients.
I speak with my friends,
family.
Every time I speak with somebody,
I give them my undivided attention.
If I'm on the phone,
I give the person on the phone my
undivided attention.
I practice doing one thing.
At a time.
By the end of the day,
I've clocked about maybe six to eight
hours of practicing concentration.
Six months later I become really good at
concentration.
12 months later,
I'd become really good at concentration.
The best way to become good at something
is to take a tool and insert it into a
reoccurring event in your life and this
is the best way to become good at
something rather than to create another
practice in your life.
Just take a tool and insert it into the
practice,
into a reoccurring event in your life.
So your homework is to give someone or
whatever you're doing,
your undivided attention.
Pick one person in your life for the
next one month that you will give your
undivided attention to.
Every time you speak with that person
can stay completely focused on them.
Keep your awareness on them.
The rest of the day you can go ahead and
be a squirrel,
but on just whenever you're speaking
with that person,
give that person you are and divided
attention and you need to practice and
bill in incremental steps.
The other thing we need to learn to
develop is how willpower,
right everybody is born with various
levels of willpower.
But one thing we never get taught to do
is to actually develop willpower.
And willpower is like a muscle.
I call it a mental biceps.
If I could draw a biceps around my mind,
that would be my willpower.
The three ways to develop willpower.
One,
finish what you begin to finish it well
beyond your expectations.
Three,
do a little bit more than you think
you're able to do.
All of these three ways require effort
and that effort is willpower,
right?
So how do I develop willpower?
I take these three methods and I apply
it to things that reoccur in my life.
What's something that reoccurs in my
life everyday,
everyday I sleep.
What a great opportunity to develop
willpower.
Before I go to sleep,
I floss,
I brush my teeth,
put on my pajamas,
I go to sleep.
When I wake up in the morning,
I finished the process of sleep.
How do I finish?
The process is asleep and then the bed
everyday.
So everyday I wake up in the morning,
I make the bed.
What's something else I do every day?
Every day I have breakfast.
If I have time to make breakfast,
I have time to eat breakfast.
Then I have time to do the breakfast
dish and put it away.
Right?
So finish the process that I begin and I
bring this into everything that I do.
Then throughout the day,
I develop willpower.
The more end practices,
the better I get.
Now,
I have tremendous amount of willpower.
After six months,
I've developed a lot of willpower.
Every time my awareness drifts away,
I used that mental muscle,
that willpower to bring my awareness
back.
Then I used the powers,
the concentration that I've developed to
haul my awareness on what I'm focused on
and because I'm focusing on that where
my awareness goes,
energy flows in my now my energy is
flowing to.
It's what I want that starts to manifest
in my life.
That's why it's so important.
Firstly,
to understand there's a separation
between awareness and the mind.
Two completely different things.
You control where your awareness goes.
You control where your energy is flowing
and you control what's manifesting in
your life and use your powers of
concentration and your willpower to hold
your awareness on the priorities in your
life.
The next thing we wanted to do is to
learn to manage energy in our life,
right?
This is based on the premise that we
only have so much energy each day.
We have a finite amount of energy each
day.
Each day we have this much energy.
We take our energy and we invested into
people and things around us.
We keep investing,
investing,
investing.
Until we have no more energy left,
we get exhausted.
That's usually around 11 or 1130 or
midnight.
We go to sleep,
I energy builds up again.
We go out the next day and we invest our
energy into people and things till we
have no more energy,
but,
but the one thing most people don't do
is we never evaluate who and what.
We're investing our energy.
And so I always tell people to treat
energy the same way you treat money.
It's a finite resource.
There needs to be wisely managed,
wisely,
reallocated,
and wisely invested.
No matter how rich you are,
you only have so much money,
right?
And before you spend money,
most of us think and evaluate what we're
investing our money.
And if somebody asks us for $5,000 or
$30,000 to invest into a startup or a
company,
we would ask questions.
Who would just wouldn't hand them
$30,000 we would ask,
what's your plan with it?
What are you going to do with this
money?
What's my return on my investment?
Because it's a finite resource.
So why don't we do the same thing with
energy before we invest energy into
someone or something?
Why don't we evaluate if that person or
that thing is deserving of energy?
Because if you only have this much
energy,
in fact,
10% of my energy and I gave it to John,
that's 10% I could have given to my
spouse,
my business,
the things and people that I love.
Remember the law of thermodynamics.
Energy cannot be created or destroyed,
but it can be transferred or transformed
from one thing to another,
right?
So I can't create energy.
If I give 10% to John,
I want to know he's going to do
something good with it.
Cause if it's just going to squander it,
I'd rather take it and give it to the
people and things that I love.
So why is it important to manage energy?
For me,
the greatest impetus for managing energy
is is death.
Death is the greatest impetus for me to
manage energy.
I realized that life is finite,
that I only have one life as me.
And regardless of my beliefs,
I know I have one existence and as done
the piney and what happens after death,
I'm not quite sure.
We all have different upbringings,
different religious beliefs.
Some people say when you die,
you go to heaven or hell.
it's game over.
That's it.
And nothing happens afterwards.
Some people say when you die,
you get reincarnated as a man or a woman
and other.
See,
you get reincarnated as a man.
Woman may be an insect or an animal,
but no one really knows.
We have our beliefs and we hold strongly
to them.
But no one's ever died and gone to
heaven,
taking the Selfie,
come back,
posted it on instagram and say,
look at me.
He didn't have an Hashtag Poli Gates,
right?
So we don't quite know.
But the one definitive thing is that we
know we're going to die.
And I know I have a finite amount of
life.
I don't believe life is short,
but I do believe it's fine.
And because I,
my life is finite.
I want to be extremely clear where to
focus my energy.
There's no point learning to concentrate
if you don't know what to concentrate
on.
So along with learning concentration,
it's really important to also learn what
to focus on.
So what I would recommend as a homework
is to be clear what your purpose in life
is.
One way to do this,
the suspend five minutes each morning
reflecting on what your purpose in life
is,
get to know yourself.
Most people are happy to spend time with
other people and things,
but very few people actually make time
to spend time with themselves.
So when you wake up in the morning,
take a shower,
or go to a quiet place in the house,
sit down and ask yourself questions
about you.
What do you want in life?
What's my purpose in life?
Why am I here?
Why do I love?
What am I passionate about?
How many people can generally answer
this is might say,
this is my purpose in life.
Very,
very few people.
Once you're clear with your purpose,
you know what to concentrate on and you
know what to direct your finite amount
of energy to it,
right?
So the next thing we wanted to look at
as energy consumers,
right?
People and things are two of the biggest
consumers of energy and people and
things also give you a lot of energy.
Since the subject is vast and timeless
shot,
let's focus on the people that consume
energy and how we can deal with them.
I call these people,
uh,
energy vampires,
all right?
That's what a vampire that's right.
Baits in the neck and suck the life out
of you.
And some people consume tremendous
amount of energy.
Essentially speaking.
There are three types of people.
And let's keep this simple monk simple.
There are uplifting people.
They are neutral people and they are not
uplifting people.
Let's define what this is,
what they are and uplifting person.
I spend five minutes with an uplifting
person.
I walk away,
I feel great and go like,
wow,
that was an amazing conversation.
A neutral person.
I spent five minutes with them.
I walk away,
I'm still the same and not uplifting
person.
I spent five minutes with them,
I walk away and I go like,
oh my God.
That was exhausting,
right?
And you've probably experienced that in
your life.
So then the next question is to ask is
are they an energy vampire in the two
ways to figure this out.
One is I can judge,
I can evaluate right?
Once a judging and evaluating,
judging is this.
I'm at a party in New York City in a
penthouse.
There are 200 people in the room.
The door opens.
This guy walks in,
he's got white,
choose the purple suit,
he's got a keen and the top hat.
He's wearing a chain with a big clock
hanging off his chest.
I look across the room and go,
he must be a pimp or a drug dealer does
judging.
Right?
I didn't get to know him.
I just judged.
He was a pimp,
a drug dealer evaluation as this.
I spent 50 occasions with John over a
period of two years,
49 of those I walk away from and I go
like,
oh my God,
that was exhausting.
It's safe for me to evaluate that John
is an energy vampire.
Okay.
Then there are two types of energy
vampire.
The next question is,
are they a transient energy vampire and
inherently an energy vampire,
right?
What's a transient energy vampire?
Just say John is going through a hard
time in life because his dad is dying of
cancer for example,
and for three years is it consumes a lot
of energy.
You know,
he's always down.
You need to uplift him.
He's feeling very sad.
It's okay.
You give him that energy because he's
your friend and that's where we do.
We express compassion,
empathy,
and love,
and we support our friends during
difficult times.
What someone who is inherently an energy
vampire is someone who is inherently an
energy,
has always been this way for decades.
They just haven't changed.
There's just not an uplifting human
being at all.
So how do we deal with someone who's
inherently an energy vampire?
So before I go there,
quick question for all of your,
how many of you in this room feel like
you have someone who's inherently an
energy vampire in your life?
That's a lot of people in this room,
right?
So how do we deal with someone who's
inherently an energy vampire,
right?
My who taught me the best way to do this
is to practice the art of being
affectionately detached,
but always kind,
gentle,
sincere,
and loving to its stem.
What does this mean?
So just say,
John is inherently an energy vampire.
I live in New York City.
I'm walking down fifth avenue.
I see John Walking too.
It's me.
What do I do?
Do I cross the street?
That's not very nice.
I meet John.
John Meets me.
What do you say when two people meet
each other?
I know what you guys say in Australia.
Get,
hey,
how's it going mate?
Right?
Do I say that?
No.
Do you know why you don't want us?
How are you?
Because I don't want to know.
It's true.
You have to understand I'm in the monk
business.
When I ask somebody,
how are you?
They tell me their entire life story.
It's a confession time.
So I don't even ask,
how are you?
John asked me,
I say I'm doing very well.
Thank you very much.
And then I reply,
what a beautiful day in Sydney,
right?
It's true.
I'm being sincere and being kind.
And then I say to him,
please excuse me.
I have something really important to do.
It's true.
My life is finite and I'm very clear
what my purpose is,
right?
I'm not,
I'm not lying.
And then what do people say at the end
of a conversation?
It was a pleasure meeting you.
Actually it wasn't,
let's do lunch.
Why
see you later?
Not really.
Don't want to.
Why do we say to the things we don't
mean and ask the questions we don't want
answers to.
So at the end of a conversation,
I say have a wonderful day.
Which is true.
I know he is inherently an energy
vampire,
but I do wish he has a wonderful day.
So the concept of being affectionately
detached is to not engage with someone,
right?
Just to be kind to be gentle,
to be sincere and loving towards them,
but not engaging with them.
What's another way to protect yourself
from an energy vampire is to place the
burden of responsibility on them.
What does that mean?
I'll give you an example.
I have a client of mine who's a expert
in social media,
right?
So a lot of people wanted to get
together with him,
have a cup of coffee,
a glass of wine.
Let's catch up for lunch.
Let's do dinner.
Why?
Because they want to pick his brain,
right?
And get information from him.
And he can sustained us because
everybody wants to have a little bit of
his time and his just kind of live this
way.
So I told them,
this is what you need to do.
You need to,
you need to tell this person who wants
to meet with you.
To read your favorite marketing book,
read your favorite marketing book,
write down seven key points and email it
to you.
Once you received the seven points from
the book,
tell them that you know you want to see
what stands out to them in the book.
Once you received these seven key
points,
you email them and say,
let's meet up on this day for a couple
hours and we can discuss a marketing
strategy for you,
strategy for you.
You know how many people actually read
the book and email him the seven key
points.
Nobody.
As soon as you place the burden or
responsibility on someone they know and
do it.
I travel all around the world.
I speak.
People come up to me and the one to ask
questions.
I always give them my personal email
address.
I tell him,
please don't share it with anybody.
Can you put your question down on this
email and send it to me,
one that'll give me time to reflect on
it and they can give you a proper
response.
And they always say,
for sure I'll put it all down in email
and I'll send it to you.
You know how many people email me?
Nobody emails me.
Simple little task,
right?
I'm not asking them to do yoga,
to meditate,
to read out of one nostril.
Just send me an email with your
problems.
And they don't do it.
So place the burden of responsibility on
someone.
If you are somebody who's developed a
particular skill,
you had an expert in a particular niche
and that particular area,
and you find that people want your time,
they want your energy.
And the one simple way to protect
yourself is to place a bet on
responsibility.
Turn them,
give them a simple task to do and see if
they do it.
And if they've fulfilled their tasks and
come back to you,
then go out of your way to help them.
Okay,
another thing I want to talk about,
so your spiritual practices to every
year,
evaluate the people in your life.
All right?
So go through a process of evaluation
and reallocate your energy between
people who uplift you and people that
don't evolve,
uplift you.
And this is something that I do all the
time.
All right.
Another thing I want to talk about and a
wrap up with is mental energy vampires.
What's a mental energy vampire?
Mental Energy Vampire is a unresolved
emotional experiences that are sitting
in our subconscious,
right?
Most people sub much conscious mind
looks like this.
Indian flower markets is packed with
stuff because people don't resolve stuff
as they go through life,
right?
Everything that is one pass through,
once pass through your conscious mind in
the form of experience is a resident in
your subconscious mind.
And all of these experiences have
emotion attached to them,
right?
One simple way to deal with unresolved
emotional experiences to do this
exercise called the [inaudible] Tantra,
that's a Sanskrit name for it.
And what it really is is to take a piece
of paper and write down the problem on
it.
Every experience has emotion attached to
And I want to share with you a quote
from Tesla,
which I think really income,
uh,
encapsulates the philosophy that I
believe in or that I was trained in.
In the monastery.
Tesla says,
if you want to find the secrets of the
universe,
think in terms of energy,
frequency and vibration.
Everything is made up of energy and it's
vibrating at a certain frequency.
So if I have an experience,
it has emotion attached to it,
it's vibrating in my subconscious mind.
My goal is I can't do anything about the
experience because it's already
happened.
But what I can do to help myself is to
remove the emotion that's attached to
experience.
So I take a piece of paper,
I write down the problem.
As I write down the problem,
something really interesting happens.
They experience moves from my
subconscious mind to my conscious mind
because I'm reliving it.
The interesting thing that happens is
the energy,
the emotion actually comes out of the
experience,
flows through my hands into the piece of
paper.
Now I crumbled a piece of paper and I
burn it in a fire.
It could be a garbage can,
a fireplace.
It doesn't really matter.
Does the fire destroyed any emotion?
No,
because you can't destroy energy.
But what it actually does is transform
the emotion and the paper into heat,
flame,
ash,
smoke.
And a whole bunch of different things.
I remember the first time I ever shat
this exercise was with a group of
entrepreneurs in Perth actually about
five years ago,
and one of them said to me,
he looked down to pawnee.
I realized that experiences have emotion
attached to them and I realize as well,
when you relive it or you're writing
about it,
it goes from your subconscious mind to
your conscious mind.
But this whole concept,
that emotion comes out of the
experience,
flows through your hands into the piece
of paper.
It's planted really hard to believe.
I've found painted that's a little bit
too spiritual.
I said,
fair enough.
So I asked him,
do you have kids?
He says,
yeah,
I have a couple of kids,
a foil and six year old.
And I said,
on father's day on your birthday,
did he ever make you cots?
They said,
they do that all the time.
Can you describe the codwell?
They say you usually go to the back of
the house,
they find an old piece of cardboard draw
drawn it.
They stick a bunch of things on it,
stars and,
and a bunch of ribbons.
And then on our last day on my birthday,
they hand me the con and I said,
how does it look?
They going,
well,
it doesn't look that great.
It's made by a foil.
But I said,
do you,
let me ask you this way.
If you saw it in the store,
would you pay money for it?
And they go like,
no,
no way.
But do you keep it?
He says,
Hey,
I keep every single one.
And asked him why?
He said,
well,
it's so full of love.
I said,
wait a minute,
do you use telling me,
um,
your kids?
No monk magic.
Because two minutes ago I told you about
putting emotion and a piece of paper and
you looked at me like I was the crazy
person.
And now your four year old son knows how
to do this right?
Cause he's taken a piece of paper,
put his emotion in it,
a piece of paper that you don't want,
a cardboard that you didn't want.
Put his emotion in it and now he's given
it to you.
And you hold it so you can actually
transfer energy from you.
Emotion from insider view into another
matter.
How many of you have kids and have one
of those not so attractive drawings at
home?
Do you keep them?
Why you'd never be able to sell it to
anybody?
Nobody wants to buy it,
right?
You keep it because they're so full of
love.
It's full of emotion,
right?
So you can move emotion out of you.
So the exercise here is really,
if you ever find that you have
unresolved emotional experiences sitting
in your subconscious,
consuming tremendous amount of energy,
take a piece of paper,
write it down,
and then burn it.
And an ordinary fire,
how many times do you should do right?
Well,
depending on the emotion,
if it's an intense experience,
you might have to write about it three
or four times if it's not so intense,
maybe once or twice.
So just to wrap up over here,
um,
to know yourself is one of the greatest
gifts you can give yourself.
It truly is,
right?
And most people don't really understand
themselves.
They don't understand what they want in
life.
And therefore find it extremely
difficult.
What to focus that finite amount of
energy on.
I want to leave you with two quotes.
One from my group.
The first one is proceed with
confidence,
right?
Proceed with confidence.
Believe in your ability to manifest
something in your life because you can.
How do you manifest something in your
life?
You take your awareness,
you focus it on that thing.
You know how to develop concentration
now you keep your awareness on it.
When your awareness is on it,
that's where your energy is flowing.
When the energy flows that it starts to
manifest in your life and believe in
your ability to do that and proceed with
confidence,
confidence.
The next thing is life is meant to be
live joyously.
It truly is and if you're not happy with
life,
then something needs to be changed.
If you ask most people what do they want
in life,
they'll always say to most people often
answer,
I want it to be happy.
Happiness should never be pursued.
Don't pursue happiness.
Pursue a lifestyle that results in
happiness and that's for me what I do.
I never chase happiness.
I pursue a lifestyle where the byproduct
or the lifestyle that's happened is in
order to find out what the lifestyle is,
I need to know what my purpose in life
is.
In order to do that,
I need to spend time with myself each
day to find out who and what's important
in my life.
Take that finite amount of energy that I
have each day focusing into those things
that starts to manifest in my life.
The byproduct of that is happiness,
right?
So I want to say thank you and I want to
leave you with a small gift.
Um,
if you go to this website address,
you'll find a five week online course on
understanding the mine and also on how
to develop concentration and willpower.
Uh,
you're welcome to sign up for it.
You just need your name and email
address and you'll receive that every
week on email.
Thank you very much everyone.
I hope you,
yeah,
got it.